can you guys tell i'm absolutely ripped
today i went to the gym the first time
in two months
oh my what i'm absolutely pumped right
first time in two months first time two
months my body is dying so you signed up
to the new gym your new place i did i
did
and it's it's different and the
etiquette is slightly different so it
kind of threw me off wait did you sign
up by yourself
uh yeah yeah it's impossible
i don't believe you
i don't believe you i shouldn't remember
how i did it and it was confusing
because it was all blur
he was asking dave and i was like yes
well that's just every interaction i
have with a japanese person in japan
they ask me something and i just say yes
here's how good my japanese got to this
point now yeah i can it's kind of like
i'm i'm kind of filling in the blanks
it kind of feels like you're doing one
of those mario party mini games where
you you see a part of the sequence and
you're like i think i know where the
sequence is going it's like going into a
mario party game without looking at the
controls right it's like 100 percent i
think i think this is outside now now i
i'm getting to the point where i'm
i'm i'm accustomed to
the normal flow of signing up to things
so i kind of understand what they're
saying
and i understood most of what was told
of me and a lot of it was just like hey
read this and i'm like ah so it's just
really weird when they pulled the knife
out and made me science selling my blood
oh that's you know i guess that's true
the rectal exam was a bit weird
[Music]
is it
i don't know we fact check that
[Applause]
[Music]
there was like it was like five banners
of just like really attractive white
guys and girls like
i've never seen a japanese person be
advertised on a gym before it is weird
it's just white people is like the
standard it's like
i think it's my i think it might just be
because like going to the gym in this
country is like a [ __ ] luxury because
of how expensive that's what it is it's
not just that who the [ __ ] what japanese
person has time to go to a gym that's
true also most of it don't mostly happen
you need to go in shape right and the
people that aren't in shape i don't
think they care about being in shape no
yeah they have like they're like i've
got everything i need in my life yeah
yeah yeah you'll be in shape uh i've got
my my seven levels like why why are you
working out i wasn't just like naturally
in [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
how did you get fat how did
basically yeah pretty much uh yeah i
signed up and i don't know i i mean i
i'm pretty yeah like i said i'm pretty
sure anytime this is american we had a
fact check who was an american yeah
it was american
that sounds american like joyfit 24 yeah
that's not [ __ ] american yeah that
sounds japanese that sounds like what a
japanese people think american people
yeah yes you're joyful in your fears and
it's over 24 hours there you go so it's
a joy i mean anytime fit this isn't much
better
signed up to it
uh didn't really know what the [ __ ] was
going on they took my picture i got the
key thing i signed my life away they
asked for my card yeah it worked out so
i i believe i'm signed up so
that's good i i walked in yesterday and
nobody stopped me
one thing i've noticed uh about moving
is like you know having to cancel
memberships and having to cancel stuff
is like ten times easier than signing up
to something oh yeah
it's the opposite in the west right yeah
yeah yeah cause like i i was dreading
having to cancel my gym membership
because i remember when we signed up to
our gym membership it took like 45
minutes to an hour of just reading forms
so i was just like so me and cindy had
to go cancel out gym membership and we
said one word which was just like we
would like to cancel our membership and
we had to find one piece of paper yeah
it took five minutes take five why can't
signing up be that easy yeah why would
you like no leaving fees just like yeah
use the gym until like the end of the
month it's like it's like everything
you're not supposed to do as a business
right it's like why it's like i love how
how hesitant they are to sign you up to
you it's like are you sure
you want to give us money every month
yeah yeah that's why i'm [ __ ] here
just let me get in for christ's sake
exactly the moment you leave they're
like oh thank god all right here you go
take it get the [ __ ] out
like i had to change over my internet as
well and that was
surprisingly painless because they were
like no worries did you want to cancel
your internet or did you want to move to
a new place and i'm just like it's it is
which one's easier not like it's both
the same it's just one
yeah yeah yeah
exactly it's just like yeah where's the
catch where's the camera but then why is
it like such pulling teeth when you're
like signing up for like water or gas at
a new place it's like are you sure you
want water in your place it's like yes
please thank you like i only just okay
so i moved to our current place like
what five almost six months ago right
and i only just finished finalizing my
water stuff
really yeah because like for some reason
because i got like a new bank account
and wither came a new card and for some
reason they didn't allow me to use my
new bank account
because it's not under the same name or
some kind of well you said you said the
b word bank
in japan
yeah so i was like but but i'd done it
before at my previous place and it was
pretty painless right so i was like okay
i mean you know it's just changing a
bank account how hard could it be famous
last question how hard could it be
nothing with the word bank in japan is
ever easy but what i don't understand
right is that okay so i signed up and
i'm like okay i want to change to my new
bank because like you know my money
situation has changed in this new place
and they were like sure no worries we'll
send you a form you can fill out all
your information and then mail it back
to us
all right email is all sort of thing but
anyway so they so so i think about a
month after that phone call
finally the form comes in i was like
all right i don't know why this took a
month to send out but sure fill it in in
five minutes send it off
two months later
i get a phone call and they say
uh so your bank is not
able to be used oh my god i'm like
ciao
tomate you could have told me that on
the phone
three months ago
why is it now after all this like
waiting and sending out a form that
you're finally like
they're gonna call you up and be like
yeah by the way the rate of inflation
has changed so significantly in the past
two months that yeah details all over
again yeah right have you been paying
for water since then so before it just
used to be like a bank transfer like
every month like automatically but since
then i've had to like get the form they
mail you the form that says the amount
and then i have to go to the uh family
mart or the yeah
and do it by cash yeah which just like
[ __ ] me up because sometimes i don't
check my mail every day and then there
was one month where i almost like got my
water stopped oh my god because they
just straight up didn't send me my form
and i'm like and then they called me and
they were like uh so you haven't paid
for your thing i'm like you haven't
given me the [ __ ] what am i supposed
to do
am i supposed to be like am i supposed
to go to my life
am i supposed to go to the company being
like uh sorry i don't have the form but
like trust me
i owe you guys i have to pay i have to
give you this money yeah i've realized
right that when i first moved here i
thought oh my god i can pay my bills at
the the local companies yeah yeah this
is amazing this is great yeah now i
realize it's just to avoid banks yeah
it's just like this whole car this
country has set up a system where the
banks just don't need to do anything but
they still have to have all your money
yeah basically
yeah and they give you like what is it
like 0.001
interest or something like that the
interest gets wiped out by every every
time you want to take up money that's
true
like you you basically there's less
interest than the p the the fees you pay
for like any service yeah japan is the
only country where like hiding your
money under your mattress might be a
better investment than putting it into a
bank honestly it's probably safer
don't spend money in the country like
people just don't no they don't yeah so
they're like why would we give you
interest if people are going to keep
money in that bank
weirdly is like a weird like
money-saving mentality in this country
even for people who have the money to
spend so yeah apparently the one of the
reasons uh why they didn't want to give
more money as people during the the peak
pandemic is because uh people just don't
spend the money so they would just be
giving money that wouldn't help
stimulate the economy yeah because
people wouldn't go out even if you gave
them a thousand bucks most people just
would just gonna keep it right right and
they're gonna
like i would that's not surprising
because like domestic tourism is massive
here it's just a massive issue here but
it is right it's like 90 of the economy
yeah exactly right